yo today finally launching an update to
the shoes that I made with Adams we've
been working on these for a while for
winter and uh these are them these are
the
2511s so there was a bunch of new stuff
but the highlights are definitely well
that they're matte black that's number
one but also the lining here is
reflective at Night Safety First and
they have a new completely waterproof
coating all the way around which is
perfect for winter if you live anywhere
with Seasons plus they're still
extremely comfortable but my favorite
thing that we've done is if you actually
go to this site you can try them on in
AR so just hit the try on button allow
access to your camera one time and uh
just point it at your feet and it should
recognize your feet and it will put them
on it kind of works in a mirror too but
it works best if you just point them
right at your feet and there you go you
can see what it looks like to wear
2511s you can also get them yourself
I'll link it below appreciate you guys
love you guys thanks for supporting see
you soon peace